[Musique]
la réunion accueillera en septembre
prochain le championnat du monde des
courses aventure 70 équipes mixtes
traverseront l'île de hell-bourg à saint
paul en totale immersion et sans
assistance qu'on va trouver du trek en
trouver du vtt retrouver de kayak de
rivière entre michaël demers la spéléo
va trouver du canyon
cheval et on va trouver ce qu'on appelle
des ateliers de cordes qui sont des
outils peuvent être des passages d'arrêt
tout de nous de remonter sur kourou
descente en rappel
diversidad aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut
donner comme un peu comme ce couple
voilà c'est l'existence de chaque
activité donc alors je vous donnais sa
tête mais ça donc on est aux alentours
de 160 km 160 km de trek 180 km de vtt
64 km de kayak tous confondus
[Musique]
dizaine de kilomètres à cheval et 3 on
va dire de kilomètres de diverses et
variées 23 nations seront représentées
donc deux équipes réunionnaises
ce matin les partenaires et
l'organisation se sont réunis pour les
dernières mises en place on va les
donner 15 euros de subventions et aussi
pour l'hébergement au village corail
et puis si vous voulez on est le le rond
central
on a de grosses centrales pour connecter
tous les informations et après pour
l'organisation les choix de la réunion
pour ce championnat du monde montre bien
la diversité des paysages de notre île
idéal pour vivre une aventure extrême
[Musique]
e